Our Union is based
on the tripod of democracy,
human rights
and the rule of law.
And through the European history,
we know that if we abandon
one of the legs of the tripod,
the whole tripod will topple.
Never can one be used against the other,
if we do not want to
revisit the horrible
mistakes that Europeans
have made in our past.
Europe is ultimately
an idea and a promise
that it is possible
to overcome age old antagonisms.
That it is possible to live together,
trade together,
work together in freedom and peace.
Freedom,
freedom is what
so many people fought for.
The European Union –
based on the rule of law,
democracy and
respect for human rights –
is the concrete expression of the will
of freedom of 500 million Europeans.